[Musique]
une personne nous a demandé c'est
bizarre on n'a pas l'impression qu'ici
il s'est passé quelque chose
l'ong l'a dit madame vous êtes rentré
mais vous n'êtes pas sûr d'être sortie
[Musique]
m
et
c'est un havre de paix tout droit sorti
du moyen-age entre combeaufontaine et je
sais une ancienne ferme cistercienne
retaper avec amour par un gentil petit
couple
yves nicol de la grange des charmes joli
nom pour un coût de gorge vous perpétuer
la tradition ce que vous attaquez les
voyageurs il n'ya jamais pensé il ya des
gens qui sont venus qui ont visité les
bâtiments espérons retrouver retrouver
une trace de ce qui s'est passé à 300
lycées mais en fait non vie sont
repartis comme ils étaient venus
bon il aurait peut-être aimé retrouver
des traces mais enfin bon il y en a peur
du sang par les airs si les vieilles
pierres ne parle pas les archives elles
sont intarissables
près d'un millier de feuilles par
cheminées cachetées de cire raconte l'un
des plus grands procès de l'époque en
haute-saône celui de la famille est rare
une truie hendaye de gens de peu accusé
de tout détesté de tous l'une de ses
grandes affaires qui retiennent
l'attention des criminologues c'est un
groupe qui vit un peu en autarcie
sous la férule semble-t-il date d'après
les éléments qu'on a pu voir dans le dos
et de la mer qui semblait être une
personnalité qui domine le groupe
et puis brûle commettent des larcins et
puis bon un peu plus que des vols et des
trousses ils sont violents
de 1792 à 1797 qui a le malheur de
passer par la forêt de ces mâts dont
risque sa vie
les marchands sont détrousser les
soldats roué de coups pièces d'or armée
chevaux sont des rôles jusqu'au mois de
vente hausse de l'an 5
lorsqu un promeneur et son chien tombe
sur deux corps en décomposition la
chaire de l'avant bras décharnés
constellé de taches brunâtres a déjà
travaillé supputant une sale histoire
il imagine qu'une bête affamés par les
rigueurs de l'hiver à prélevée sur les
cadavres
cette sinistre pitance y aperçoit alors
une ferme à une centaine de mètres son
premier réflexe est de s'y rendre mais
très vite il se ravise ceux là sont le
meurtre et l'assassinât le temps de
revenir avec les gendarmes et les
cadavres ont disparu mais qu'importe
cette fois les rares vont payer avec des
petites bestioles qui avait tendance à
se nourrir de pourriture qui étaient là
qu'elle ait des marques quand même
probablement de cork avaient été
ensevelis sévérac banques c'est à partir
de ces éléments là qu'il ya eu une
incrimination d'assassinât
le procès dure 15 jours il fait défiler
75 témoins mais aucune preuve
la famille est rare crie son innocence
le peuple réclame sa tête
cinq des neuf accusés sont guillotinés
en place publique au pied de l'actuel
palais de justice à faire on emmenait ou
terrible erreur judiciaire
nul ne saura jamais l'âme des damnés
ont-elles encore les lieux à vous de
voir
il paraît que les prochains
propriétaires ont prévu d'y accueillir
les voyageurs